hi steve coffin here today i want to
talk about goal setting in language
learning
uh it's important
and i think the way we set goals depends
on our level in the language
i'll give you an example from my own
language learning recently i decided to
work on my portuguese
and particularly to expose myself to
more brazilian portuguese
so i found some interesting lessons in
our library
link one wonderful series of 20
lessons by one of our members about her
travels in italy with her friend
i graduated from that to reading some
novels for which i also had the
audiobook in portuguese and it was again
in a brazilian
accent and then i found some wonderful
podcasts
uh from brazil which i've been listening
to and enjoying so the whole thing is
very enjoyable it's easy i do what i
want when i want and i know i'm
improving
no need for sort of very specific
short-term task type goals but
if i look at languages where i'm not as
far ahead
for example korean
then i have to take a much more
deliberately deliberate approach now if
we look at language learning you know
there is this common european framework
of reference and i'll leave a link in
the description and it divides
the levels of proficiency into six
levels
a12 b12 and c12 so six levels
my view is increasingly
that to get to the halfway point which
may or may not exactly be the halfway
point but it's to do the first three
of those levels
once you've done that you you basically
get to a point where the learning be can
become a more natural enjoyable
type experience
but to get there particularly the first
first step you know the beginner's step
stage you know a1 a2 you're really
fighting it looking up every word
forgetting it the structure of the
language is strange it's very difficult
even when you are low intermediate or
you know b1
and you're now accessing authentic
material but you're still having to look
up words and there's still things that
are fuzzy and yet and you can't yet
express yourself the way you would like
so
so it's still that struggle stage once
you get past that once you're a high
intermediate and going forward now you
can improve your language through this
massive exposure to interesting content
that you can find on the internet
audiobooks books newspapers
podcasts meet with friends meetups talk
all these sort of things that you do
when you feel like it and you just enjoy
the language so you learn through
enjoying but for the first three steps
it's actually heavy lifting and with the
heavy lifting it's very important to
have specific
measurable tasks and so with my korean
starting in september i'm going to do
another 90 day challenge and i'm going
to set myself very specific goals for
those 90 days i'm going to make sure
that i read 450 000 words of korean
which is divided by 90 days what is that
5 000
words a day
uh and i'm going to listen to the same
content we have content in our library
at link that the podcast that i had
transcribed that i've been meaning to
get at and i'm going to do them
systematically even though they're
difficult for me and i'm going to save i
think
in my mind there's something like
20 000 words and phrases that i'm going
to save and i expect
that this is going to increase my at
least passive vocabulary by another 30
000 words you divide that by 90 and you
get whatever the number is i'm not going
to do it in my head right now so i'm
going to set myself those very specific
targets because it's like if i'm if i'm
exercising i have a general goal i want
to be more fit or i want to maintain my
fitness level but if i say okay you're
going to do these exercises you're going
to do 20 push-ups three rapid you know
three sets of 20 push-ups you're going
to lift this weight and that way you're
going to do your you know core exercises
have a very specific regime i don't have
to think about what i'm going to do i
just have these specific tasks that i
have to achieve and i think the same is
true for language learning and after all
and and of course that's why at link we
introduced these introduced these uh you
know the activity index these
measurements and it's mostly a
measurement of your level of activity if
you can force yourself to be active to
put the time in just as with exercising
you will achieve results
some people may achieve more results
some fewer in some areas than others and
so forth but you're forcing yourself to
do it because you have identifiable
tasks that are measurable so that's what
i recommend you do when you're in that
heavy lifting stage
and that's what i'm going to be doing
with korean and my hope is that all this
heavy lifting is going to take me to
pass that breakthrough point in the
language so that i can start just
enjoying my korean the same way that i
enjoy my portuguese right now so thank
you for listening bye for now